the Joe Rogan experience it it baffles
me confidence what is what does it
really mean there was a period of time
where I felt like I did I did the first
Ironman and then I went and did Tropic
Thunder and then I was doing the first
Sherlock and I had my shirt off I'm
seeing Marshall I was like I was all
over the place and it just felt like I
was I was hitting triples no matter what
I did and and then people are like are
you really as confident as you seem and
I was like I guess right now I am yeah
and then and I think this goes I mean
this reminds me we were just talking
about the McGregor cowboy fight coming
up you know it's like it's you gonna go
to that I'm gonna watch it how can you
not watch it you know - brilliant
souls who cannot lose neither one of
them can afford to lose this fight wow
that is a matchup yeah particularly
cowboy doesn't want to lose there's no
but there's this guy who's the the
poster child the guy who's the the one
right the chosen one that's Connor and
then this cowboy who's like I think I
can [ __ ] that guy up the journeyman yeah
yeah so confidence you know there's been
times when I felt I'm in possession of
it and then you want to let go a little
bit because it's only ever the moment
and life guiding you the wind - so at
your back that you're like wow are you
just are you just you know jumping over
the waves and all that by yourself and
you're like you bet I am but there's a
physics to the moment man moment machine
whatever and the wind's at your back and
then the wind does what the [ __ ]
windows and it changes and if you're
left there thinking what you know so I
think it's great to be in full
possession of what you would call
supreme confidence and then see what
happens if you don't hold on to it so
hard because it's great but it is a bit
of an illusion because like everything
else it's always changing and every day
the reset button the spacebar gets
pressed and it's like now what
yeah the reset button yeah that yeah you
kind of have to have a confidence to
jump into some of the roles that you've
taken though but I see what you're
saying like that you don't want to hold
on to it because it can come and go I
remember
Warren Beatty who I learned so many
amazing things from of tuna movie called
the pickup artists with Molly Ringwald I
remember okay and he was kind of the de
facto producer of it uncredited and
taught me a lot about just acting and
what it was and he said he said what's
your what's your action in this scene
and I was like oh no he's asked me I was
like I'm my action I'm picking up girls
he does
what's your action in this scene and I
was like I'm driving a car and he asked
me like you know that things sometimes
when someone asks you a question and
just you get caught flat-footed you guys
know your action is you're trying to go
to work but you're getting distracted by
this addiction you have to trying to get
laid so your action is you're trying to
get to work and I was like oh yeah he's
right and you said always know what your
action is because then when you come in
in the morning confident or when you
come in in the morning that can't hit
your ass with both hands you know what
to do mmm so to me one of the great
lessons I learned from him was ileana
just boiled down what it is you're doing
whether there's a camera around or just
what am i doing today today I'm showing
up and I'm trying to be honest and and
also to to listen and learn but really
my action today is I'm today is I'm
beginning a process of promotion Warren
Beatty is another guy who learned how to
put his guns down yeah yeah that's like
yeah I think I remember watching that
Madonna movie remember when he was
dating Madonna truth or dare
yeah and he's hanging around with her
you know she's in the throes of Fame and
everything he's like yeah like he's
never seen it yeah but he's an older
gentleman now he's honest and you know
he's hanging out with her and just
shaking his head and you know that kind
of marked it for me or Warren Beatty
just realize all right let me step away
real quick if I had to talk to him one
things I would ask him is what was it
like when Carly Simon writes a song
about you that's got to be a trip I so
many I mean we should if you we should
do a whole session just about things I
learned from Warren Beatty yeah I'm
telling you I would imagine he's a
brilliant guy clearly
[Applause]